[Music]
welcome to every damn day as you can see
there's only three of us because it's
close to the holidays everyone's had too
much eggnog and now they vomiting I also
know my nook and I'm still here bitch
she's a trouper but we are going to
persevere and today we're gonna review
the three times we were definitely
Michael Scott mine is the first one
throughout that clip detective Michael
Scarn I'm with the FBI
think about this what is the most
exciting thing that can happen on TV or
in movies or in real life somebody's a
gun that's why I always start with a gun
because you can't top it you just can't
I'm supposed to meet my doctor here have
you seen him he's very angry midgets
boom please Michaels goon FBI you know
you did boom boom yeah you thought you
could get away with your little ruse
didn't you didn't you well you did
because I know where you hid the
diamonds I've been onto you and your
little friends for weeks okay you shot
me great what stop why okay you can't
just shoot everyone in the scene if you
hadn't stopped the scene you were seen
where was going okay what about the
scene they sent up no it wasn't no
Morgan it's no no Michael once you give
me all the guns you have just get rid of
all your guns and give me great okay oh
not only am i Michael Scott and that
scene I have been every single
improviser in the beginning in the first
bad yeah that could have been me so I I
don't know if you guys know this but I
started doing improv in high school
yeah at a local theater if you could
believe and I invited my parents because
I was like so proud you know I was like
I'm on the star and so my parents were
like very like stoic Russian people and
they were so disappointed they were like
no one memorize their lines no costumes
just t-shirts it was just like they were
very obsessed I think I guess when you
think about it what we're doing is trash
I the only improv show of my parents and
the only I never liked even when I took
classes I stopped going to class shows
because I was so bad my I just looked
out in the audience and I was bobbing so
hard I just see my brother go took me to
lunch you were like are you sure you
want to do this so my my embarrassing
improv Joey has nothing to do with
improv I was at a TV festival last year
and Jordan Klepper was there who Jordan
Klepper of the Opposition and I went up
to him and we started talking I was like
oh my improv team is going against your
improv team tonight at cage match was an
improv show and then he was like oh
crazy crazy and then it was going well
and then I was like hey so like applying
for your show like how do I do that I
just saw him his smile go like oh yeah
you know you're gonna have to talk to
like why I wouldn't know he was like
even trying to help me then he's so nice
so nice why would you do that I thought
things were going well and I was like I
really need this to happen
Jordan it's like I don't know why you're
doing a bit it's like you are a smart
person and then I do things like that
I know I make big mistakes all right
who's next
oh yes my clip is Scott's tots throw
that up who here's done something stupid
in their lives like skipped out on study
hall or mix up the difference between a
gym and B gym that sort of thing show of
hands
anybody yes but you okay well me too
I've done something stupid which I would
like to share
[Music]
should we go no no we're okay it's a
it's a double period all right I came
here today because I promised you
tuition and tuition is very valuable but
you know what's invaluable is intuition
you know what that is that is the
ability to know when something is about
to happen does anybody out there have
intuition no it's gonna happen next
nobody okay you gonna make me say it all
right
I am so proud of all of you Derek and
LaFave and and Ben and Ayana and Mikayla
and Nicky and Jason and I'm sorry okay
so we're spacing your name
I'm Zion but Kayla's younger brother
well Zion I am NOT going to be paying
for your tuition which brings me to my
main point and that is that I will not
be able to pay for anybody's tuition I'm
so so sorry
did you promise to pay some people's
tuition no but you know we all make
promises about volunteering or
charitable works that we can't really
pay and one time I was like wandering
through my neighborhood because I was
sad and I saw a soup kitchen and I went
enough and I was like you know I'm gonna
volunteer here and I like people like
who are you I don't know I just like
want to volunteer and I did I did the
whole day of volunteering and like I
helped people a lot other I learned
people's names and they were like oh
you're great like we need more people
like you and I was like okay I'm gonna
organize your systems inventory like I
didn't tell them that but I had that in
my head yeah and then I was like I'm
gonna come here every week so they like
we're like okay we're gonna email you
this is great and then the week
turnaround I was like oh man I'm like
really busy and then like to this day I
can't figure out how to politely get off
their list sir you're still there like
sorry yeah ultimately do you think you
just wanted soup and that's what
happened was like do you think I could
take the extras home have you made
promises that you keep every day of my
life to myself do I write a list of
goals and then it's like the coffee
wears off and I in high school did the
elderly buddies program just like you
visit with an old person you just like
hang out with them for a little bit and
you know I'd would Forge those numbers
oh this old person doesn't know if I'm
here for an hour
[Laughter]
sorry you guys know that STDs are
rampant in elderly homes yeah I believe
it amen like really just they're after
it yeah oh man
so something look forward to all right
Hannah are you ready
what's your cleanup carbo-loading
carbo-loading
she's carbo loading carbo oh boy you got
it
fettuccine alfredo time to carbo-load
are you a caramel letter I am loader
every morning well I I really have
Aerith on with my friend were trained
like all this stuff and then it was the
day before when she had to go pick up
her packet I hadn't even signed up
because she was like are you kidding me
she was like uh you told me you sign
that and I was like I meant to but I
didn't so I wait with her to the sign up
and it was an extra $50 but I I was so I
didn't want to be mad at me I just
signed up I was like well what's 12
miles uh-huh and then we went home and
made pasta and started drinking pretty
heavily wine because that's also a card
I'm doing the stitch I was so hungover
and not trained but I made I did two
hours in five women oh that's crazy
Charlie in two minutes I beat her yeah
bitch so I was like oh well what are you
running for and I was like I didn't
realize that like all runs or for
something oh okay the charity is my body
what I finished I looked at it and I was
like I had to look at the sheet and I
was like whoa it we're running for aspic
a-- and my friend was like the asp yeah
i don't i don't know what good running
is cuz in high school my mile time was
13 minutes ah
that's terrible yeah and i was like
trying
not walking I was jogging the whole time
I feel like you're like a runner that's
like yeah yeah legs are really moving
but you're so in it yeah it's that's
aerodynamic your legs have to go dead
you drag just fighting the wind yeah you
you like food and like fitness yeah okay
one time I got it one time I got these
gluten-free pancakes like this pancake
mix and I made like 20 and I ate them
all in the morning I think I've told you
guys this story once I don't know um
well I ate all the gluten-free pancakes
and then I was like I feel great I'm
gonna go for a run to Fort Greene Park
and then I like like went for the run
and when I got to the top of the hill I
was like I got a poop oh I gotta get rid
of all this and it's like now I got to
do this now but I'm like I don't want to
do this in a public place so I like like
ran and then I had to walk home and then
I was like I gotta find a place to go
poop in public and then but I didn't I
made it home but it was so much like
iceberg do you know what I'm talking
about like and I was actually like wow
are you ever like weirdly proud of like
what you do yeah look at that shape yeah
sometimes I'm like should I take a photo
just cuz it's like that's crazy that
that came out of my body yeah you know
take a photo send me the rule when I
visit my parents houses I have to use
the downstairs bath oh wait they have a
rule for you there's a rule just for me
no yeah cuz my my dumps are so large
like that I always break the upstairs
story like that
the rule is I got it and that's a bummer
so I'm a lady okay Hannah you got a
shoutout for us yeah so for everyone out
there calling me annoying uh I know this
I grew up with parents I have a brother
I have co-workers that I have a boss
like I know unpleasant so your comment
means nothing to me and dropping the see
bomb heard it before so let's get a
little more original this guy though G
Smith
he said truther shot-caller is the
greatest gift known to man Wow pretty
cool compliment for me I came up with
the idea pretty good yeah and it's so
crazy because I was like looking for
comments and Joan was like you know what
this is from my mother is huge and can
you just tell them that you wanted to do
that cuz yes I wanted to do this I get
off on this sexually it's fetish for me
and I get off on the fact that people on
YouTube are watching it as well all
right well you heard of your first turns
a little freak and make sure to check
out full episodes of The Office on
Comedy Central every week please like
comment subscribe and check out us on
Twitter at extra damn day
[Music]